it's a [ __ ] disgrace  thing is i drive a mack truck  so it cost me 480 to get from the top of  my street to the bottom of it so this is  not new news to me that's no [ __ ] use  to me it's terrible right gene i hate it  i don't like these prices i remember  when i could fill up my car for  eight dollars  eight dollars had taken from new york  to north carolina  see my grandmother  daisy you should make me some pie  goodbye  these prices it's a disgrace no but in  all seriousness tell me about it there  was a point where the the gas prices  around the world going crazy brought in  in the united states yeah everything was  [ __ ] hunky dory no it's not [ __ ]  story now  a gallon from florida to [ __ ] san  francisco  harmonize with me and hold me back to  all through the night you're shining  bright i'm your boy  [Music]